rubba kathleen
all right this video needs a little
better context I haven't been making
videos for quite a while because I've
been on my book tour and usually when
you come back here like I what games are
new I can't wait to play all the new
games this is all I could find this is
this is literally the best I could find
so there's a get any better than this
do you want to warn you though it's
scared of [ __ ] out of me when I launched
it so 2 3 2 1 ok
3 3 you ready you ready you sure it's 3
2 1 oh Jesus Christ
[ __ ] hell ok this is good as again
welcome to put a pie chart
let's wait for the title you've seen the
title you've seen that I'm sorry
the story of this game
are you excited is that your face man
you can jump around you have faces and
we have faces Polly
we know home I'd say it's a great place
it's a great punch it how you can you
and you should face up to you uh okay
it's going Island City looks like
everything's unpacking okay so basically
we are fed up we are faced men ah we can
also do this now oh yeah we can use our
bases as a flying carpet but the places
will run out uh and there are enemies
I'm told
yep there is okay dodge it there we go
no problem no problem no problem at all
okay oh god this game like I said holida
near probably like want to run 500 hours
in this game
ah we're at the beach I love the beach
there's banana bananas I don't think
they look like that but I'm I think
better change into my face trunks the
face Frank let's G perhaps something a
little more traditional for my face is
red so uh yeah this is the game and you
want to help people to go our paper
plates now what will I serve the burgers
on everyone
place your wheels upon my mini how
they're using them as plates all right
what are the ladies was the hot babes
Cameron yeah I can't stop running for
some reason thank you it can be
destroyed by them you need an umbrella
lady no problem I'll make one with my
faces and I'm placated thanks you're
welcome you're welcome you're welcome to
write into her neck
how are we supposed to play without a
net don't worry broski's Oh God
face man is here to save the day oh
let's get this blue facts Oh God
and oh shut up and [ __ ] you up with my
face it'll be shooting [ __ ] dick test
that's right protect ya carpet mode
activate
you know camera guy wears in face to
face continents and base copter okay now
of course of course this is this is a
game what happened
what's that just get on with it
I would save one leg two best game
yes
face mad oh I love it
take that and this and this face man
you're not going anywhere son oh okay it
keeps going it just keep just keeps
going
I want to cry no this is best best game
best a less yep give s massive your real
hero there's still one more question
it's [ __ ] me - this is a very
awkwardly long can shape a hair comb
play freeze my legit facing around so
you're gonna leave me facing all over
town a salient neighborhood Omega P in
my living room in decay it's my it's my
it's my job okay so I'm gonna play this
game with Matthew McConaughey Matthew
McConaughey McConaughey for coming in
playing this game thank you alright
alright alright alright
indeed Matthew alright so I'm here oh oh
that's oh you had someone Matthew
yes I've hit someone I will hit someone
- for you Matthew thank you hit him we
did a Matthew - this don't worry Matthew
I got your back thank you look after me
please I'm Matt's best friends forever
that's right oh god Matthew I'm down
apologize I'm so sorry
hey what's your next next project is
gonna be Matthew and next project I was
really actually looking forward to being
in this PewDiePie video
oh god you're down again Matthew I'm
down on the floor why why why must
Matthew die
I've died what is happening what is
happening what is happening
you guys are coming with me to my
dungeon deaf get him get him oh oh oh
get Rick get right get right yeah
correct
we did it Matthew did it hey proud of us
best game this was the best ground let's
go and cook some some some some south
Caesar Caesar salad best game all right
so the final game I once this is a
pretty good episode so far I think yep
it's cold I'm dead where are my keys ah
here we are
what the [ __ ] this is kind of cool all
right so we're driving and we can grab
stuff I know we can grab stuff okay what
the [ __ ] is going on i I I am five more
five more candies others I don't I'm
scared I'm trying
and trying ah no don't know I'm sorry
okay so to prevent any form of the
permanent brain damage we're gonna end
all right well that's that's it for
today's [ __ ] show in it thank you for
watching I will see you hopefully next
time with them with a little little
setup it's gonna be breakfast